mais dans le genre bonjour bonjour et
vous êtes à la fin de votre mandat comme
secrétaire général de la francophonie et
vous allez briguer un deuxième mandat
c'est de notoriété publique
maintenant il ya quelques semaines le
président emmanuel macron a appuyé
ouvertement la candidature d'une autre
candidate qui est la ministre des
affaires étrangères du rwanda et à ce
poste
comment vous avez réagi quand cette
nouvelle est sortie je pense qu'avec
tout le respect que je dois au président
la république française
qui nous restait qu'à prendre acte c'est
à dire prendre acte d'une décision qui
est la sienne mais la france est un pays
avec 83 autres quoi la francophonie ses
84 états et gouvernements
et chaque chaque pays peut chaque chef
d'état peut exprimer son point de vue
mais ce qui me conforte c'est vraiment
l'appui très forts du canada incluant le
québec le nouveau-brunswick ça a été le
cas en 2014
c'est aussi un bilan c'est un rapport de
confiance aussi avec avec d'autres états
et gouvernements dans la francophonie
qui qui montrent leur appréciation de ce
bilan c'est à dire de tout ce que j'ai
su impulser déployés en m'appuyant sur
la feuille de route qui m'a été confié
par les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
lors du sommet de dakar
c'est le moment où je suis élue
secrétaire général de la francophonie et
aider et de des résultats produits de
l'impact on va parler des résultats tout
à l'heure mais vous croyez vraiment
qu'on peut à l'intérieur de cette
organisation-là aller contre la volonté
du plus gros donateurs qu'elle habitait
n'est pas aller contre le volonté
la décision se prend par consensus si
elle se prendre à erevan
c'est la règle
l'idée n'est pas d'être contre quiconque
je crois que nous sommes à un moment de
vérité pour la francophonie
c'est à dire sur ce que porte cette
organisation ses fondamentaux
son action son positionnement aussi sur
l'échiquier multilatérale c'est de ça au
fait dont il est question est ce que
vous étiez surprise avec un parce que
c'était quand même assez surprenant
comme sortie oui il ya eu un moment de
stupéfaction et et puis ensuite on
entend
on soupèse des arguments il y en a
certainement qui est de l'ordre de la
certaine realpolitik
mais moi je suis dépositaire d'une
organisation demande à d'une feuille de
route et c'est là dessus que je m'appuie
que pensez-vous de la candidature de
madame et de la mission des smad à
mushikiwabo
et est ce que c'est pour vous une ça
sera éventuellement une adversaire quand
vous allez défendre
moi je suis pas du tout dans l'adversité
ni dans le duel ça ça regarde les médias
les musées ont envie de le proposer aux
deux présentées ainsi je connais madame
tchéquie wabo parce que elle a été
ambassadrice du rwanda au canada elle
m'a présenté ses lettres de créance
alors que j'étais gouverneur général du
canada
elle a vécu longuement à ottawa je n'ai
aucune animosité à son endroit
elle elle accepte ce pari et moi j'en
porte un aussi mon pari c'est c'est
vraiment celui de mandat qui m'a été
confié d'une feuille de route que j'ai
eu à porter d'actions qui ont été
conséquentes dans un contexte mondial
quand même de grands grands défis défis
sécuritaires défis de développement défi
aussi de défense des droits et des
libertés
j'arrive à un moment vous savez dans la
francophonie on n'a jamais vu autant de
pays notamment francophones d'afrique
mais pas seulement
engageant presqu'en même temps des
élections qui sont des grands moments de
tension et l'action politique de la
francophonie a été quand même des plus
intenses on n'avait jamais vu ainsi donc
cette francophonie politique c'est celle
là aussi qu'il faut défendre cette
francophonie d'accompagnement pour
l'état de droit la démocratie pour
vraiment aussi les objectifs de
développement que se fixent les pays
dans la lutte aussi contre le
réchauffement climatique
c'est tout ça qui m'importe maintenant
madame gens vous allez évidemment
défendre vos résultats du premier mort à
quels sont les deux ou trois éléments
élément peut pas parler de tout dont
vous êtes la plus fière qu est ce que
vous allez mettre de l'avant pour dire
voilà la francophonie doit me choisir
pour un autre mandat j'ai besoin de ces
autres
année pour accomplir ce que j'ai
commencé je sais quoi je pense que ce
qui a été formidable c'est que la
promesse engagé à dakar dont le thème du
sommet était les femmes les jeunes en
francophonie le vecteur de paix acteurs
de développement en est à tulle je
dirais d'inclusion inclure davantage ses
forces vives mais vraiment dans dans
toute la trajectoire tracée par la
feuille de route vous allez avait au
sein dans ce sens ça absolument c'est à
dire que nous allons par exemple arrivé
à erevan avec une stratégie qui est la
plus solide que la francophonie est
connu sur l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes l'autonomisation et les
droits des femmes et des filles ça c'est
important
en plus ce qu'il y avait ce qu'il y
avait au coeur de la feuille de route
c'est la stratégie économique de la
francophonie et j'ai voulu langage et de
manière très inclusive en soutenant
l'entrepreneuriat les initiatives
économiques qui sont portées par les
femmes et par les jeunes en soutenant
les objectifs de croissance des pays en
engageant vraiment des actions qui
permettent à ces pays de mieux défendre
leurs plans de développement économique
et social rassemblant beaucoup aussi en
nous appuyant sur tous nos réseaux par
exemple les ministres de l'économie de
l'industrie
les ministres citent des finances faire
en sorte que nous soyons là pour les
accompagner dans leur dans leurs
négociations avec les institutions de
bretton-woods comme le fonds monétaire
international l'organisation mondiale du
commerce et tout cela donc devenu un
exemple un exemple qui qui va parler à
nos téléspectateurs
parce que là on parle des grands
principes des grands organismes qu'elle
savait principe oui je comprends mais
justement un exemple concret une action
qui a vraiment favoriser les jeunes les
femmes dans un pays concret par alors
puisqu'on parle ici par exemple de ce
qui a fait la différence pour le québec
et son développement au canada
il ya eu aussi la mise en place de
dispositifs d'accompagnement des très
petites petites et moyennes entreprises
et industries
on appelle ça des incubateurs des
accélérateurs des espaces collaboratifs
nous nous avons déployé rien que sur
l'afrique sur 13 pays d'afrique et de
l'océan indien
de ces dispositifs et nous avons
accompagné aussi l'existant c'est à dire
pour permettre de mieux structurer les
plans d'affaires les objectifs les
capacités aussi de ses moteurs de
croissance que sont ces très petites
petites et moyennes entreprises qui sont
déterminantes et faire en sorte que ces
entrepreneurs trouve vraiment plus de de
compétitivité et de et de capacités pour
se positionner sur le marché à la fois
locales sous régionales régionales et
voir le marché international rien que
dans la francophonie 84 états et
gouvernements sur les cinq continents
nous avons à la fois l'offre qu'il faut
amener un niveau de qualité sur des
standards de qualité et nous faisons
cela avec entre autres le réseau de
normalisation pour la francophonie qui
est basé ici au québec et il ya la
demande et l'idée c'est d'établir des
passerelles pour que voilà ils ont créé
plus de synergies économiques dans la
francophonie
et ça c'est précieux ça veut dire que
par exemple systématiquement rares
rencontres et les chambres de commerce
et d'industrie rencontrer ses forces
économiques rassembler aussi en réseau
des ministres nous venons de nous
mettons en place en ce moment un réseau
des ministres responsables des économies
numériques
la question du numérique elle est
fondamentale nous avons une stratégie
numérique maintenant madame chan et vos
détracteurs disent que la francophonie
comme organisation et j'aimerais bien
que vous répondiez à ça n'a jamais été
aussi marginalisée quelle année depuis
ces dernières années
d'accord vous l'avez déjà entendu ou
c'est la non pas ça par contre je dirais
que c'est une appréciation qui est
totalement à côté de la réalité
la francophonie par exemple désormais
elle est appelée au conseil de sécurité
pour témoigner de l'état du monde
j'ai eu moi-même a apporté un plaidoyer
et sur par exemple les opérations de
maintien de la paix nous travaillons
avec les nations unies depuis presque 20
ans maintenant sur les opérations de
de maintien de la paix leur efficacité
et ses opérations sont déployés pour la
moitié d'entre elles dans des pays de
l'espace francophone
les sièges avant vous avez été appelé
depuis 2 dès mon arrivée en 2015
j'ai tenu à ce que l'oif l'organisation
internationale de francophonie soit
considérée positionner comme un acteur
incontournable parce que c'est c'est je
dirais ces menaces que l'on qualifie d'
asymétrique dont le terrorisme nous
traversent entièrement nous dans
l'espace francophone savez nous sommes
et nous apportons avec les expertises
que nous savons a rassemblé un appui
considérable
par exemple sur les centres de veille
les centres de l'analyse de données et
de renseignements qui permettent de
renforcer la lutte si essentiel contre
le terrorisme maintenant on est en jeu
je voudrais rajouter autre chose aussi
je rentre des nations unies où j'ai été
appelé avec d'autres chefs
d'organisations internationales et
régionales partenaires dix nations unies
a participé à une retraite où nous
discutons d'une chose essentielle pour
le renforcement du multilatéralisme d'un
partenariat sur la base d'une action
plus concertée et coordonnée entre nous
organisations partenaires
parce que nous sommes tous ensemble sur
le terrain je veux dire pour affronter
et des situations de grande tension dans
nombre de pays et j'ai tenu de sueur sur
ces dernières années par exemple durant
tout mon mandat et dès mon arrivée à
faire en sorte que justement il y à une
action plus concertée et coordonnée et
cela produit des résultats
maintenant on dit ça j'ai résidé remet
de désamorcer des situations extrêmement
conflictuel et de grande tension
on dit que président macron justement
voudrait ram
mais l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie à sa mission première qui
plus mission culturelle mission de
défense de la langue que la francophonie
ce serait un peu trop dispersée à ces
questions économiques stratégiques et de
défense c'est à dire que à cet égard là
encore avec tout le respect que je dois
au président de la république française
ce que je tiens à dire c'est que la
francophonie dès le départ n'a jamais
été une organisation strictement de
promotion de la langue française et et
de voilà je vous cite à léopold sédar
senghor l'un des pères de la
francophonie qui dit la chose suivante
notre francophonie n'est ni une tour ni
une cathédrale
elle s'enfonce dans la chair ardente de
notre temps et ses exigences la
francophonie s'est toujours défini aussi
dans cette coopération active avec la
langue française comme trait d'union
pour agir ensemble sur les exigences de
notre temps et c'est ce que nous
continuons à faire nous ne sommes pas du
tout dispersé si vous regardez les
déclarations des sommets successifs qui
rassemble des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de la francophonie vous
regardez les feuilles de route
les attentes qui sont formulées par ces
chefs d'état et de gouvernement sont de
l'ordre de justement éducation-formation
stratégie économique stratégie numérique
sécurité stabilité action politique pour
la démocratie l'état de droit la défense
des droits et des libertés
c'est ça hein aux fondamentaux c'est ça
donc nous ne sommes pas là strictement
sur et la culture notre approche de la
culture
elle est quoi comme une composante aussi
du développement comme une je dirais une
chose essentielle aussi pour renforcer
la cohésion sociale le dialogue donc
surtout ses champs nous sommes sur nos
fondamentaux nous ne sommes absolument
pas disperser et sur un multilatéralisme
renforcer la francophonie est reconnue
est attendue aussi pour sa plus value
son approche ces expertises à ces
réseaux qui sont très forts et qui est
qui et qui voit la faune sans sa force
maintenant il est un secret de
polichinelle que ce qui vous a fait le
plus mal
durant votre mandat c'est des questions
de gouvernance ce sont des dépenses pour
les rénovations de l'appartement
à paris ce sont la voiture privée est ce
vrai ou non chauffeur privé pour votre
mari ces questions de gouvernance ces
questions du gouvernement ils vous ont
fait mal et c'était des journalistes et
des journaux des enquêtes qui ont révélé
sam mais c'est aussi les politiciens
qu'ils ont repris le premier ministre du
québec la insisté là dessus à plusieurs
reprises il faut régler les problèmes de
gouvernance
halloween est fait comment répondez-vous
d'accord alors une chose est certaine
c'est que il y a eu effectivement une
campagne acharnée et extrêmement
accablante qui a produit
je dirais beaucoup de désinformation
parce que les faits sont les suivants je
suis élu secrétaire général de la
francophonie
je suis installé installé par
l'administrateur en poste à l'époque le
québécois clément duhaime dans un
appartement qui est propriété du
gouvernement du canada qui était vacant
cet appartement présentais je serais des
voiles à des défauts d'infrastructures y
avait pas eu d'investissements à cet
appartement depuis un certain temps
le gouvernement du canada lui même admet
qu'en l'état il n'est pas habitable mais
prend entente l'administrateur monsieur
duhaime prend entente avec le
gouvernement du canada pour m'y
installer et prendra la charge de l'eau
et f
les travaux nécessaires pour en faire un
appartement de fonction donc tous a été
entendue est transparent d'elle je pense
que nous avons tout dit sur la question
je pense que l'administrateur actuel de
l'oif qui a pris fonction le 1er avril
et les travaux ont été exécutés je suis
arrivé à paris le 5 janvier 2015 et ses
travaux exécutés par l'oif avec
l'assentiment et sous l'aspect ctions du
gouvernement
canada ont été effectués entre janvier
et avril donc d'autres gens mais
maintenant vous avez parlé aussi le
chauffeur privé il n'y a pas de
chauffeur privé pour mon époux il y à
une équipe de chauffeurs de l'oif
d'accord et dans il est vrai que par
exemple ces chauffeurs sont mis aussi à
disposition de la résidence et il arrive
dans les temps très rare où mon mari et
l'a effectivement où un chauffeur peut
être mis à disposition
mais ça c'est inscrit dans le contrat et
ça a toujours été le cas y compris pour
mes prédécesseurs
donc on me fait un procès avec une hyper
personnalisation de la chose ou est ce
que l'on l'on me prête un train de vie
qui n'est pas qu'il n'est pas du tout
conforme à la réalité pourquoi le
premier ministre du québec monsieur
couillard a encore mentionné quand il
faisait référence à son appui à votre
candidature muschi l'appui votre
candidature de façon conséquente et à
votre
deuxième mandat il a quand même parlé
des problèmes de gouvernance qu'il
faudra le régler et à paris je pense que
la gouvernance
alou lief est à bien des égards
irréprochable c'est à dire que nous
sommes sous des règles de gouvernance
qui sont celles des organisations
internationales et l'administration
d'organisations internationales en ce
moment même alors que le secrétaire
général antonio guterres est de l' onu
engage des réformes
il engage aussi un code de transparence
appuyez sur l'initiative internationale
en faveur de la transparence de l'aide
c'est à dire que ce que j'ai trouvé moi
en arrivant la francophonie c'est un une
organisation qui avait un fort déficit
de communication
il ya beaucoup d'informations par
exemple ils sont destinés à nos
instances mais qui ne sont pas
accessibles au public et moi dès mon
arrivée j'ai voulu une chose d'une part
comment construire une culture de
l'évaluation et de des résultats
développer sa cette organisation où je
trouvais qu'il y avait quand même des
lacunes
nous sommes soumis à une reddition de
comptes régulière avec l'appui d'un
audit externe qui est menée par la cour
des comptes du maroc en ce moment
précédemment en début de mandat c'était
la cour des comptes de france est qui et
qui agit avec une les deux cas une
vigilance absolue et qui salue aussi
notre collaboration constante à
l'administration de l'oif à toutes leurs
requêtes
j'ai instruit aussi avec
l'administrateur adama ouane de
l'organisation intentionnelle
francophonie aussi un audit interne une
équipe d'audit interne qui voit aussi à
l'évaluation des risques
l'identification des risques la gestion
de l'eau et f
nous avons aussi une commission
administrative et financière où nous
nous rendons compte aux chefs d'états et
de gouvernements à travers aussi le
conseil permanent de la francophonie de
toute l'administration d'organisation je
pense qu'en ce moment le code de
transparence que nous mettons en place
et j'y tiens absolument va nous
permettre de prendre des décisions
cruciales qui sont soumises
d'état et de gouvernement sur qu'est-ce
que nous rendons publics
c'est ce que fait aussi en tonneau
goûter rsa pour l'onu d'accord qu'est-ce
que nous rendons accessible pour une
meilleure traçabilité
je dirai à la fois de l'aide une
meilleure traçabilité aussi de l'impact
de nos programmes et une évaluation
constante aussi je dirais de 2 de notre
notre efficacité notre taux d'exécution
par exemple nous l'avons amené à 90%
ça aussi il faut le prendre en
considération donc bien sûr il y a eu
des pressions faites par une septième
campagne dont nous parlons est qui qui
finalement apporté des informations qui
étaient totalement à côté à côté du réel
donc voilà maintenant effectivement
campagne qui a été quand même assez
soutenu ici au québec mais et qui a
étonné beaucoup le reste de la
francophonie un jeu vous là vous l'avez
vraiment mais sa présence à ce que le
journal de montréal et quelques autres
journalistes il ya quand même des
députés conservateurs qui en chambre ont
fustigé monsieur trudeau de donner un
appui à votre candidature pour un
deuxième terme il ya la caq au québec
qui peut être 20 former le prochain
gouvernement au québec qui a dit s'ils
sont élus ils n'appuieront pas votre
candidature comment expliquez vous et
c'est cet animal gergorin car je pense
que d'une part
je je pense que nous vivons dans un
monde en ce moment où des l'action de
certaines médias appuyé sur une approche
très populiste une approche acharnée
mais qui peut être vécu aussi par des
politiciens presque comme une sorte de
d'action d'intimidation je vois l'impact
que cela peut avoir sur les politiciens
mois face à tout cela je reste
responsable
un responsable c'est à dire dans la
nécessité de rendre compte des faits de
la réalité d'une administration d'une
gouvernance qui est toujours perfectible
que l'on peut moderniser mais nous avons
aussi des faits qui ne sont pas
rapportés par ces médias et qui montre
l'irréprochabilité de de notre de notre
gouvernance au sein de cette
organisation quelconque les avait une
pantalon dès maintenant pour arriver à
erevan avec une gamme onemi chilien à
votre propre
moi je pense que s'il n'y a pas à
remonter elle est aussi d'une
responsabilité partagée
c'est à dire face à l'action de certains
médias qui en quelque sorte mise sur le
spectaculaire la désinformation et je
dirais que celle là peut aller jusqu'à
de la diffamation très grave et à cet
égard cela vient créer un effet qui peut
être déstabilisant à la fois pour la
démocratie pour les institutions de la
démocratie et de l'état de droit et pour
des organisations internationales
nous vivons dans ce monde là nous en
sommes conscients et c'est face à cela
que nous devons nous situer et je pense
que la responsabilité politique et aussi
celle d'un discernement face à ces
pressions qui sont exercées et il faut
se prêter à un exercice je pense
constant de vérité maintenant madame
cent pour terminer d'ici 2050 la
majorité des francophones seront
l'afrique est ce que ça ne voudrait pas
dire qu'une africaine devrait une femme
africaine surtout devrait être à la tête
de l'organisation
très bientôt je pense que notre
organisation est d'abord une
organisation internationales et
multilatérales sur les cinq continents
et je pense que le choix fait par les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement et de
tenir compte de cette dimension aussi
international et de l'énergie que l'on a
envie d'amener à cette organisation
moi vous savez en 2014 ce débat-là sûr
il y a une règle non écrite qui voudrait
que ce soit un africain qui soit la tête
de l aïr it cet argument aussi hérité
des africains qui disent ah au fait
mais pourquoi ne pourrions pas nous
pourrions nous pas choisir un candidat
ou une candidate qui soit qui amène
cette énergie nécessaire pour engager
plus de synergies au sein de cette
organisation pour je dirais engagé cette
organisation aussi sur un échiquier
multilatérale face à tous les défis
auxquels nous avons à faire face
et moi je jeu j'ai je jouis de cette
confiance là c'est à dire sur ce que
j'ai à apporter qu'est ce qui a
influencé le choix en 2014 et ce sont
les chefs d'état eux mêmes qui me l'ont
dit d'une part le fait d'être une femme
de synthèse qui incarne bien cet espace
de la francophonie quand vous êtes 12
janvier kim ce qui à la fois du sud et
du nord qui portent cette double
sensibilité qui apporte aussi une
énergie qui permettent d'engager cette
feuille de route extrêmement exigeante
et ambitieuse mais qui participe d'une
ambition légitime ce que nous sommes
nous connaissons notre force cette
capacité de mobiliser je connais ma
capacité de mobiliser je me souviens à
l'époque et j'en ai fait la preuve
à l'époque un 2014 vous dit
et une phrase qui m'est restée en tête
l'afrique marche dans mes veines
bien sûr hui de cette origine là
maintenant et vous avez eu l'occasion de
visiter l'afrique encore beaucoup plus
que quand vous étiez gouverneure
générale vous avez vous avez toute la
francophonie là et est ce que vous avez
vraiment l'impression que vous êtes prêt
de ce continent que vous comprenez ce
continent bon je vais pas revenir aux
dépenses mais quand même quand on dit
que vous lors d'un voyage à new york
vous avez une note d'hôtel de 50000 $ ou
4 nuits
excusez moi mais vous prenez vous ça
mais d'où prenez-vous ça je vous écris
nous déplaçons nous nous déplaçons aux
nations unies nous sommes en pleine
mobilisation autour de l'accord de paris
sur la conférence climatique qui doit se
tenir à paris et qui est qu'est vraiment
un temps fort
nous sommes traversés nous la
francophonie par les effets dévastateurs
du réchauffement climatique
nous avons une expertise dans l'aar en
ce domaine et ce que nous avons fait à
l'onu à ce moment là nous avons mobilisé
les chefs d'état nous avons porté une
campagne et nous avons porté une
concertation est essentielle et les
frais dont vous parlez couvre vraiment
le déplacement de toute une équipe qui
est appelé par les nations unies pour
apporter son concours
un sur ce avec une réflexion très solide
sur le réchauffement climatique et et la
réalisation de la 2 de l'accord qui doit
être engagée ensuite à la conférence sur
le climat qui se tiendra à paris c'est
ce que nous avons fait alors évidemment
quand vous faites ce type de déplacement
et que vous allez sur place aux nations
unies où est ce que vous allez mener une
concertation qui va impliquer des chefs
d'état vous arrivez avec une équipe et
une bonne partie de cette équipe venait
entre autres de l'institut de la
francophonie pour le développement
durable qui est basé ici à québec
donc vous voyez la façon dont des formes
les propos on dit cinquante mille
dollars pour 4 nuits d'hôtel et on eu ce
qu'on ne dit pas que ce n'est pas ça
c'est une mission qui s'est déplacé pour
vraiment jouer pleinement son rôle de
plaidoyer aux nations unies
tenir des concertations qui ont été
déterminantes ensuite pour pour la
réalisation de l'accord l'accord de
paris et nous sommes là sur ce chantier
depuis 1992 depuis vraiment le sommet de
la terre à rio
c'est nous qui formons des négociateurs
francophones c'est nous qui mobiliseront
en français les pays de l'espace
francophone pour que ces pays notamment
développement soit en capacité de venir
négocier dans ces moments très forts qui
sont déterminants pour les enjeux de
développement pour eux en france aient
porté leurs perspectives porter leurs
solutions et faire état de je veux dire
de leur réalité
c'est notre rôle ça regardez comment le
menu deux s'engagent sur des choses
pareilles ou d'autres agences onusiennes
ou d'autres organisations et vous vous
dirais franchement investi sur cette
mission aussi importante
la somme que vous dites pour mettre à
l'oeuvre une équipe c'est de notre
devoir et cela a été fait de manière
responsable
madame je vous croyez en vos chances
évidemment à erevan
je connais la francophonie vous allez
être là encore pour quatre ans je crois
à la francophonie et je me sens
dépositaire d'un mec très très important
c'est à dire qui est celui d'une
organisation qui est née vraiment d'une
volonté et d'un idéal
porté par cette cette vision d'un
humanisme intégral est universel cette
coopération très intense et très active
entre des pays
2 / vraiment sur les cinq continents qui
ont envie de faire front ensemble face
aux défis de notre temps et ça c'est
extraordinaire
merci merci